so here's some palladium wire very very
small sample of palladium wire but we'll
get it out and see if we can find it
palladium is a material that an element
that is quite similar to platinum so
most of these metals so-called noble
metals or platinum group metals are
found in South Africa and they're the
main supply the mines in South Africa in
fact it's so small I can hardly see it
and palladium is a compound which is
recently become much more widely used by
chemists because palladium metal and
palladium compounds are used widely and
in organic chemistry that's the
chemistry of carbon compounds for
joining different groups together with a
bond between two carbon atoms the
so-called heck reaction so most of my
colleagues who do organic chemistry at
some stage or another employ this
reaction of palladium so this is a small
sample of palladium palladium is used to
make electrodes it's also used for
forming electrical circuits it's a very
very very expensive metal it's a
precious metal it's refined from ores
from South Africa Australia and also the
former Soviet republic palade the price
of palladium has gone down recently
though because it's ordered with
platinum and the value of platinum or
the demand for platinum has gone up
because of auto catalytic converters
palladium is used to catalyze organic
reactions but also as the electrode
surface in electrochemical processes got
some much better samples of palladium
else whether it's also used in the
pharmaceutical industry but again there
it's not quite such a good reaction
because you have to remove all traces of
palladium from the products at the end
so there are other ways that people
using in my in my own work I've used all
my students have used palladium quite
widely
the catalyst for adding hydrogen to
organic compounds so again it's one of
the elements that's really been quite
good to me